get all the crumbs right onto the floor
dr. kay you want on your side off
I love sisters I have a sister don't get
here my dress is classic
hey everyone I'm a dejar welcome to
Abby's kitchen and today I've teamed up
with best five who sponsored this video
to bring you a very special Mother's Day
collaboration with joining and yeah so
these are the daughters of my good
friend Abbi Langer and we know how hard
mom's work especially Abbi
so today I wanted to treat her to a
really nice healthy sweet Mother's Day
treat so what are we making so many
campuses we are but also we're gonna put
our own special little touch on these so
what are we gonna do to them yeah we're
gonna decorate them and I think mom's
gonna love this so girls tell me why do
you love your mom so much okay she likes
baking much she loves baking what about
you doing what do you what do you love
about your mom I love that she loves
this and that she makes great meals well
I know she makes good meals because I've
seen them on Instagram and they look
amazing so you girls are really lucky
and today we are going to treat your mom
so she's really lucky too so let's get
to it
All Right girls so first thing we're
going to do is cream together the butter
and the sugars and we're going to do
this in our KitchenAid stand mixer so if
you have what you go in with the butter
and how about Jordan you go with a brown
sugar and not the maple syrup crank that
guy up number how we talked about
bringing it up perfect she's going to
turn this on all right
well Jordan how about you put in our
almond flour give it a good shake if he
knows how to clean up she just throws it
on the ground how do we go in with a
little bit of vanilla that's going to
help flavor it up and you can do a
little bit of the almond extract
how will we give that little pinch of
the salt in there is he not the whole
thing just a pinch and a nice pinch of
cinnamon as well and who knows how to
crack an egg
are you so here's an idea I'm going to
put this behind my back and you guys get
to guess which hand it's in and that's
going to be who gets to put the egg in
alright ready and go
that one's what you're picking you're
picking the other one yeah well next
time next time okay
crack it in alright so we got our dough
already I'm just going to break this in
half and we're going to vacuum seal the
other half so that way we can make
cookies at another time maybe even with
mom how's that them yeah good okay so
we're going to roll these ones out and
we are going to put a little bit of
flour down because you want to make sure
nothing sticks and when you're ready
we've got some different shapes here
okay guys so which one what shape do we
like the best before you get started
which one do you want to do how are you
lad you want to do a lot yeah one more
okay one more and then we're going to
put this into the oven at 350 degrees it
only takes about ten minutes for me to
just bake off and just get slightly
golden brown we're going to make icing
and I promise you're gonna love the
icing I show yeah I'm pretty sure so
careful careful careful
I know you just want to put it all over
everything but who wants to carefully
give this very slowly because it's going
to make a master for two hours yep but
nice and slow oh it's like a sandstorm
of sugar nice and slow okay
that's why Oh oh that's fine that's
that's what happens when I touch my
children how to slowly put that in you
know okay bring it all link put it in
there we go that's all it takes just a
little bit off we go
and we're going to go really slow
so before we get to decorate let's clean
up because we got a bit of a mess on our
hands here from from making the icing so
we have our three bowls of icing we're
going to color them all different means
three different colors and I've got the
food coloring right here you can find
natural food coloring online if you
prefer and what I'm just going to do a
little bit of the pink in here what's
your card shaver color here's more -
blue pink purple red green orange yellow
purple green blue purple panky blue I
like all the colors in the world all
right so we've got some icing I'm going
to show you and I just snipped the tip
out there we go and look we're gonna
draw oh wow
I think your mom's gonna love these what
you think you're gonna save any for her
he's gonna eat them all maybe maybe if
she bees nice they says they know don't
eat them yet we got to put them away for
Mama
oh you didn't have one false one I can't
deny a young child a cookie what do you
think
taste I can look up Astro Boy I guess we
can't win it with them okay guys so we
are going to print some cards and pack
them up so that we can give them my mom
ran after and how does what all right I
think there other up for anything at
this point after all their sugar so so
there you have a guy some delicious
almond sugar cookies that are perfect
for Mother's Day what do you think your
mom's gonna think I think she's gonna
like them what do you think you can
write them below I think so and of
course if you guys enjoy this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with what you're gonna be
making for Mother's Day subscribe to the
channel and thank you so much to Best
Buy for supplying all the awesome
equipment that we used in this video to
make these awesome cookies well thanks
so much guys bye
[Music]
you